I'm not for Turing them as victims in
the sense that would we be doing the
Jews a disservice by saying that they're
being killed I mean there are two
different things you see that is exactly
why they would give half truth 11 our
point which no one can deny is actually
someone much softer than I when these
issues shiri nearby the the Nobel Peace
Laureate she keeps talking about the
laws when she talks about women's rights
she's not talking about him and wearing
the veil or not she says that the
fundamentals of every society is in its
laws if you say that a girl can be
married at the age 9 or 13 by the
consent of her father and the male judge
if you say that in a society women who
wear judges like shearing can now be
should be defrocked and they cannot act
as judges because they kept their
emotional and they cannot judge well if
you say that women's bodies are sexual
entities that deprived men of their
senses if you say polygamy is ok those
people who are targeted by you are your
victims I'm not making it up this is not
something that I make up you know to say
women are victims but really they're not
not but you say the other aspect of it
as well that not because of the Islamic
Republic but because women have been
resisting this and that every single
thing I've written the first article I
published in English actually before the
New Republic article it was in 1994
maybe it was about the issue of women
and I brought the example of shahrazad
and 1001 nights of how do you resist I
say these things about the way they are
suppressed to tell you how do they
resist you know and and I bring
many examples of the way they resist but
you can't deny that aspect and just say
they're just vibrant entities in a void
you know so I think that those people do
a disservice why are these women heroic
if there is nothing repressive going on
there just heroic because they live you
know our Iranian women really as free as
they used to be or are they really as
free as Hillary Clinton is you know
these are the issues that people should
and then they say okay in America you
have so much nudity and sexual you know
promiscuity which is not good and we
should fight against but in America at
least you can come into TV or you can
write articles or you can fight it you
know first of all I can do that in the
Islamic Republic I go to jail for it if
I come out like this and and the second
thing is that in a miracle you are still
given much a choice how to dress you can
wear the veil you can come in the web
Britney Spears does and I prefer that to
not having a choice
you